This is an interesting photograph.
Where do you think this is?
Take a guess.
That's right, we're on an airplane.
I think we are on a 747 jumbo jet.
Look closely, can you find the number 747?
Great job, you found it!
It's on the cover of the magazine in the seat ahead.
Some plane rides are very long.
You will get hungry.
It's time to eat.
Wow, look at all the food we get to eat today.
I see some chicken and rice.
Oh, there is some seafood and salad, too.
Look, we have apple juice to drink.
What's for dessert?
Hmm, it seems some kind of pudding or yogurt.
Did I miss anything?
It is amazing how the airplane food is packed into small containers.
I wonder if everyone gets the same meal.
Let's eat.